soy la doctora anna mapfre garcía
doctora en historia del arte por la
universidad de valència mi especialidad
en el doctorado es la protohistoria del
santo grial la protohistoria del santo
cáliz de la catedral de valencia' hoy
vamos a hablar de algo que realmente nos
llega al corazón de todas aquellas
personas que siempre hemos sabido que
existe algo más una búsqueda de lo
sagrado una búsqueda de la divinidad del
santo grial la reliquia más buscada del
medievo occidental todos ustedes dirán
el santo grial
pero eso eso no existe he de decirles
que si el santo grial es una sagrada
reliquia que se venera desde mil 437 en
la ciudad de valència en su catedral y
que los últimos estudios llevados a cabo
desde la universidad de valència
demuestran que esta sagrada reliquia
conocida con el nombre de santo cáliz es
nada más y nada menos que una verdadera
copa de bendición es un verdadero cosa y
dos de hace 2000 años donde empieza esta
historia pues sin duda en jerusalén aquí
tenemos un mapa de la época
de jesús en jerusalén y este lugar el
aposento alto está marcado de una forma
muy especial todas aquellas personas que
hemos tenido la suerte de entrar en la
ciudad vieja de jerusalén pasear por sus
calles y dirigirnos a los diferentes
puntos que la tradición cristiana
contempla cuando hemos pasado justo al
lado de la tumba de david
y hemos rezado con nuestros hermanos
mayores los hebreos y hemos podido
acceder a ese espacio y por hoy
custodiado por los musulmanes que es el
aposento alto y hemos recordado las
palabras de jesús en su último peso en
su última cena pues todas aquellas
personas que conocemos este relato de
amor
nos embriaga una emoción indescriptible
cuando vamos a tierra santa cuando vamos
a jerusalén aquí en este espacio en
donde me encuentro ahora es un espacio
museístico que cuenta de alguna manera
cómo pudo ser esa cena esa cena de pesa
esa cena de celebración hebrea tan
importante para todos los cristianos
así es que os voy a invitar a que
conozcáis este espacio aquí en valencia
que se llama aula grial al mismo tiempo
que os voy contando la historia de esta
sagrada reliquia
esta es una réplica de la copa de
bendición que existe actualmente en la
catedral de valencia' es una réplica
realizada en resina porque la copa
original es de una gema semi preciosa
hoy sabemos gracias a los estudios de la
óptica física que esta copa está
realizada en ágata sin embargo el
tratamiento del corte de la piedra así
como todo el tratamiento estilístico de
la misma indican que en origen se trató
de una pierna tardíos esta piedra sar de
osh es muy importante porque se situaba
dentro del pectoral del sumo sacerdote
de jerusalén en este pacto oral
la piedra de sar dios representaba nada
más y nada menos que la tribu de ayuda
la tribu de judá
precisamente la tribu del linaje de la
casa de david así tenemos que la piedra
que representa este sagrado vaso
corresponde nada más y nada menos que a
esa tribu donde
tened yo jesús pero además hay algo muy
curioso y es que cuando se someta a un
estudio volumétrico esta pieza responde
a dos cualidades hebreas muy importantes
su altura es de cuatro dedos justo medio
palmo hebreo y la cantidad de líquido
que puede contener hasta la misma ranura
es de dos
revich y medio
lo sorprendente es que los dos primeros
dedos de esta copa y sólo los dos
primeros de dos corresponden justo a 86
centilitros lo que es un re bit medida
mínima necesaria para celebrar un peso
judío medida mínima necesaria que debían
de beber todos los hebreos que querían
celebrar pesa hace 2000 años la talla a
mano de esta piedra sea cotejado con
todos los vestigios que existen
actualmente en el museo de israel en
jerusalén coincide la talla manual
coincide la volumetría coincide además
la significación de la piedra con la
cosmovisión hebrea por tanto en valencia
tenemos el único cosidos de hace 2000
años que curiosamente
el o de hebreo el sar dios
en esa cosmovisión hace referencia a la
regla del amor justo las palabras que
desprende el evangelio de san juan' en
esa última cena de jesús así es que esta
es la presentación de la sagrada
reliquia conocida como santo cáliz de la
catedral de valencia'
la historia de la sagrada reliquia del
santo cáliz es una historia viajera como
podéis ver en nuestra credencial del
peregrino porque tenemos una credencial
del peregrino que vertebra el camino del
santo grial la ciudad que da origen a
este gran camino es precisamente la
ciudad de jerusalén ahí en ese aposento
alto es donde discurre la última cena la
cena donde jesús se despide de todos los
suyos con un mensaje de amor universal y
este mensaje de amor universal es el
mensaje que queremos que guíe a todos
los peregrinos y caminantes hasta la
ciudad de valència y vosotros diréis y
desde jerusalén qué pasó con la sagrada
reliquia
pues en el año 70
tito livio destruyó por completo la
ciudad de jerusalén
mucho antes amigos familiares conocidos
de jesús salieron de la ciudad rumbo a
roma la capital del imperio romano
cuenta la tradición que fue el propio
sampedro quien acompañado por un séquito
de familiares y amigos de jesús se fue a
roma
a predicar la buena nueva
os invito a que me acompañéis
estamos en romang estamos en el siglo 1
sabemos que la religión cristiana no es
una religión oficial es algo que se
tiene que vivir en la clandestinidad
porque el imperio romano aboga por el
politeísmo si imaginamos esa primitiva
comunidad de hebreos mesiánicos que
creen en jesús en una ciudad imperial
como es roma hay un personaje que a
partir del siglo tercero es fundamental
en esta historia se trata del archi
diácono san lorenzo tenemos que hay una
gran persecución por parte del emperador
valeriano a todos los cristianos del
imperio
en roma en el año 258 a mediados de
agosto el papa san sixto segundo y seis
de sus siete diáconos son tomados presos
y van a morir en el camino cuenta la
leyenda que san lorenzo antes de que se
lleven al papá habla con él y el papá le
pide que ponga a salvo los tesoros sin
duda alguna el tesoro más importante no
era otro que ese vaso de bendición que
había sido utilizado y custodiado como
una sagrada reliquia desde el principio
de los tiempos
en roma en una de las catacumbas más
importantes
hemos encontrado este mismo cáliz
dibujado con una mímesis tan
absolutamente cierta que no cabe duda
alguna que en ese hipogeo el más hebreo
de todas roma se encuentra un dibujo de
esta sagrada reliquia que fue salvada
por san lorenzo san lorenzo era de
huesca osca en hispania hispania era un
lugar de cierta tradición cristiana ya
en aquella época
cuando el diácono san lorenzo envía esa
reliquia hispania no lo hace de forma
aislada un nutrido grupo de cristianos
que ya conocían los rituales de servicio
de ese cosidos van también con esa copa
de bendición hasta óscar y allí una de
las representaciones más curiosas que
vemos en roma' que es la mujer que porta
el santo cáliz la sagrada reliquia a una
mesa de bendición pascual a una mesa de
celebración
también figura esa iconografía de mujer
que porta un sagrado cáliz entre sus
manos en todo el pirineo aragonés vamos
a verlo
estamos contando que esta sagrada
reliquia es una sagrada reliquia viajera
y como muy bien habéis comprobado hemos
pasado por jerusalén hemos pasado por
roma y de roma ahora estamos en los
pirineos del reino de aragón
curiosamente en el siglo 11 hay una
eclosión dentro del arte románico
en la pintura con un motivo iconográfico
muy específico que no se repite en
ninguna otra parte de todo el orbe
cristiano conocido es un motivo
iconográfico muy curioso que pone de
manifiesto el papel de la mujer dentro
de esa primitiva asamblea romana estamos
viendo como esas pinturas en los ábsides
que representan a las vírgenes con
cálices es un motivo singular que jalona
todo el pirineo de la corona de aragón
todo el pirineo del reino que custodiaba
el santo cáliz en el lugar más especial
y todo el orbe cristiano en el real
panteón monasterio de san juan de la
peña un espacio idílico bajo una gran
montaña que tenéis que conocer
vamos el reino más importante al sur de
la europa cristiana es el reino de
aragón el reino que custodia la reliquia
más buscada del medievo occidental donde
se encuentra esa reliquia se encuentra
en el real panteón monasterio de san
juan de la peña un espacio sagrado donde
los reyes de aragón iban a reponerse de
todas sus heridas y lugar donde se
preparaban para esas batallas que por
territorio tenían que desarrollar bajo
el amparo de la divinidad como veis el
monasterio de san juan de la peña es un
lugar idílico un lugar mágico en donde
solo el entorno es capaz de relatar
y esa historia esa historia que contó
chrétien de troyes chrétien de chua en
el siglo 12 a través de su libro lee
conté del gral este libro fue escrito
para el príncipe de alsacia un noble
francés que conocía perfectamente el
santo cáliz el santo grial pues justo un
año antes había ido a este reino de
aragón y había pasado por san juan de la
peña
allí le mostraron un objeto fascinante
que era mostrado nunca mejor dicho con
una ritualidad con un ritual muy
específico quien portaba esta sagrada
reliquia entre sus manos pues
curiosamente chrétien de trova en el
siglo 12 no dice que lo portaba un
obispo ni tampoco un bono ni un
prohombre no
este santo cáliz esta sagrada reliquia
este santo grial el aportado por una
dama tal cual aparece en las catacumbas
de roma tal cual aparecen en los ábsides
románicos ese motivo iconográfico que en
la historia del arte es sin igual y va
ligado continuamente a la figura del
santo grial vamos a conocer más cosas
sobre esta literatura del santo grial
que llenó toda europa hasta nuestros
días sobre el mito de la búsqueda del
santo grial
pero no solo la literatura medieval ha
llenado páginas y páginas sobre el mito
de la búsqueda del santo grial todos
nosotros tenemos que acordarnos de un
personaje que en uno de sus films en una
de sus aventuras encontró a un templario
que le dijo
has encontrado aquello que buscas has
encontrado el santo grial indiana jones
se elige el cáliz de un carpintero pero
yo creo que estaba equivocado antes os
hemos dicho que el cáliz es de piedra
que es un verdadero koski 2 de hace 2000
años perteneciente en toda su globalidad
la forma en que está concebido la forma
en que está tallado su forma fútbol u
métrica el significado de la piedra todo
hace alusión a esa cosmovisión hebrea
vinculada directamente a la figura de
jesús tengo que deciros que
bueno indiana jones de alguna manera se
ha retractado y para que veáis que no es
un bulo un fake new os invito a que
disfrutéis de este pequeño vídeo que lo
explica todo
he vuelto para decirte que estaba
equivocado
el objeto más perseguido durante siglos
nunca pudo ser de madera te mostraré una
piedra preciosa tallada a mano hace más
de 2000 años y el misterio de su pequeña
cicatriz su viaje desde jerusalén hasta
roma y finalmente españa'
donde seguirá sus pasos a través de una
ruta llena de aventuras descubrirás una
pintura renacentista de la última cena
con un detalle que no podrás olvidar
sabrás todo acerca de un símbolo que
unido culturas y credos babas mostraron
al mundo
[Música]
sabrás por qué fue custodiado durante
siglos bajo una inmensa roca hasta que
al fin llegó a la ciudad que dominaba el
mediterráneo
[Música]
conocerás la historia de los reyes que
más lo desean
héroes anónimos que arriesgaron su vida
político de traducir en su enigmática
inscripción que seleccionará y abre
[Música]
y todos los detalles por fin encajarán
he venido a esta valencia para que
puedas conocer el auténtico santo grial
[Música]
bueno como habéis visto nuestro camino
empieza en jerusalén pasa por romà llega
hasta los pirineos de san juan de la
peña baja por todo el reino de aragón
atravesando huesca zaragoza teruel y por
fin eclosiona en la provincia de
valència en su catedral aquí tenéis una
réplica maravillosa en orfebrería
realizada del santo grial como hemos
explicado solo la copa superior responde
a esa sagrada reliquia hebrea el resto
la parte áurea es un añadido que se
realizó en el siglo 11 en el propio san
juan de la peña un añadido que de alguna
manera lo que indica es que esta piedra
es una piedra sagrada es un santo cáliz
elaborado para ser ostentado con ambas
manos
y no para ser utilizado como una copa de
misa al uso tal cual las podemos
encontrar todos los domingos
en la santa misa esta sagrada reliquia
cuando se le elabora ésta
áurea forma este relicario se la hace
precisamente para no poder tocarla con
las manos en el momento de mostrarla y
hacer como explicado antes
la elevación de esta sagrada copa
bueno explicaros que en el mundo de la
ciencia hay grandes
e investigadores que han tratado esta
sagrada reliquia desde el siglo pasado
tenemos
oñate tenemos a el doctor antonio
beltrán tenemos incluso desde el año
1700 36 estudios del doctor sales y
alcalá que ya hablaban de la concepción
de la piedra como una característica muy
importante en toda la cosmovisión
oriental del mediterráneo de hace 2000
años
estamos ante
una sagrada reliquia contrastada y
estudiada desde la ciencia os invito a
conocer mucho más sobre el camino y su
historia a través de un ensayo que nació
desde la tesis doctoral que realicé en
la universidad de valència es un ensayo
que muestra no solamente la historia
sino también el conocimiento que
envuelve a esta sagrada reliquia su
nombre el santo grial
podéis obtenerlo en cualquier parte de
el mundo de habla hispana puesto que
bueno la editorial distribuye
absolutamente a cualquier parte del
mundo y bueno si tenéis interés pues
podéis acceder a él a través de los
portales de internet
haréis un trabajo doble los beneficios
van todos destinados a la asociación
cultural el camino del santo grial la
asociación que de alguna manera vertebra
todo este territorio para que desde
cualquier parte del mundo cientos de
peregrinos y caminantes podáis conocer
toda la historia este es el libro del
que se ha hablado y que conduce al
verdadero conocimiento de esta sagrada
reliquia todo aquel que alguna vez haya
buscado el santo grial
puede dirigirse aquí
te espero en sus páginas